ils se sont connus sur les bancs du
lycée 16 ans plus tard danakil est
toujours là le groupe marly choix c'est
dû régler aux inspirations jamaïcaine et
aux textes engagés
on peut dire ce qu'on veut après mois
les mots les étiquettes engagé militants
ont fait la musique qu'on fait il ya des
chansons qui sont plus sérieuses sur
lesquels on essaie de poser des
réflexions carrément employons les gros
mots il y en a d'autres qui sont plus
légères parce que la musique ça sert à
tout ça aussi notre art ce la musique
donc comme un peintre irait peindre un
petit peu les émotions que lui donne sa
vie bah nous ça devient des notes de
musique ça devient des paroles groupe
indépendant danakil était sur la scène
du scarabée le 30 juin dernier pour le
festival les artistes pour l'eau
l'association du même nom vient en aide
aux dogons populations autochtones du
nord du mali
on était justement sur une période où on
se tournait vers le mali nous mêmes pour
l'enregistrement de l'album à l'époque
le troisième album qui est enregistré
là-bas les années qui ont suivi moi j'ai
su aller m'installer au mali j'ai passé
deux ans donc on était vraiment dans une
dynamique proche tous les uns des autres
et effectivement on sait on sait on
s'est entendus dès le départ nous notre
mission c'est de leur faire des forages
d'essayer de le retrouver l'eau pure
c'est ce qui s'est produit
l'année dernière dans 2013 et 2014
nous avons développé une ferme avicole
et agricoles grâce à l'accès à l'eau on
a commencé par un courage qui a donné
une autre est très pure la rue résonne
or dernier album sortira le 7 octobre le
premier single 32 mars est inspiré par
le mouvement nuit debout et nous saurons
nous est passé de vous la république du
sang de nos voix